what's happening reject nation it is dc
fandom 2021 day got germany
got coy with me coy's gonna be spending
the day with us as we cover whatever
we're actually interested in covering at
a dc fandom koi is the comic book expert
he is going to out star us in every
single way today and i am all for it so
make sure you follow him on youtube and
his social medias today but first thing
we kick off with is first look at black
adam this long-awaited dwayne johnson
movie are you a fan of black adam i am
and i think this is the thing that's
gonna pivot dc into a different realm
we've had this phase one of dc and i
think this is gonna be phase two is
gonna be largely shazam two and black
atom based i think we're gonna yeah
mythical and magical forward and then
batman's gonna be our grounded one but
more on that later but i think this is
gonna be a zeitgeist shift let's see if
he can pull off an anti-hero or if he's
just
wayne johnson
so
oh
[Music]
smells like an indiana jones tomb raider
baby
oh there you go
wow there you go
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
dude venice
oh
man oh my god
you're so [ __ ] into that
i've been so sucked into that
yeah [ __ ]
i mean yeah that looks cool they said
first look so first look it is the first
look and i think the costume looks great
you're getting a sense at least like the
opening mood tone i mean you really
gotta distinguish this from the actual
shazam movie as much as possible what's
more brutal i mean immediately brutal
darker i really do want to see how
dwayne johnson doe does handle the
dialogue that's like that's because my
association with black adam obviously
from the shazam comics and like some
video games and shows that i've seen him
in and stuff and i'm like i just i
actually have a hard time wrapping my
head around his performance as black
adam and
i'm more about like how are you gonna do
like are you gonna do a voice i don't
think you're gonna do a voice
i'm not sure he has the look he has the
physique and this was a really cool
tease of the kind of mood it is like
yeah darker shazam movie essentially
yeah in a lot of ways like where shazam
was inexperienced black adam knows how
to do all this already upon awakening
and he's out for
i'm assuming some kind of vengeance but
uh corey before you overshadow us
take it away yeah no i agree with a lot
of what you said i was really pulled
into this when it ended i was like no no
show me more and i love the look of this
indiana jones-esque you know more
ancient
type of maybe even swashbuckling vibe i
mean there's a lot of ancient history
behind black adam and yeah contrasting
from shazam that stuff looks really fun
and cool and my biggest wonder is
because dwayne johnson makes such a
living off of being this likable
charismatic guy and his persona his
voice his look is so distinct how will
he sink into the anti-hero or the
villainous role um but you know i'm kind
of happy to have that anticipation of
like i'm i'm ready to be wowed by that
when the movie comes yeah but the
ensemble of all the other new comic book
characters coming in here like hawkman
adam smasher like those that's all
really cool to see and so this is gonna
feel very different i don't know i'm
gonna i of course have i have faith in
the rock i love him i love the guy he's
like man the best leading man out there
but coy let's take a break john okay so
what i'm thinking is first of all i love
to use the hood because one of the
things that makes them stand out is that
billowing hood and they actually made it
feel ominous and intimidating which i
think is gonna be one of the things that
separates like we said the need to
separate from shazam is the tone and
you've already got a very dark amblin
borderline r-rated movie in the first
shazam it's it's a youthful dark horror
film in many ways especially the
boardroom scene so how do you make this
a more mature version of that while
still maintaining that pg-13 i think the
way you do that is actually make it dark
in a very literal sense you make black
adam a darker film a more indiana jones
film so you still have that amblin 80's
tone but you go a little older a little
more mature what i'm curious about is
it's a film about an anti-hero and how
do you make that something that's
interesting i think what you do is you
lean into the rock being so likable and
you make him do all unlikable things but
use the audience's subconscious opinion
of the rock to make you like him so
there's nothing that the rock does
that's likeable in the beginning but
then you therefore have the rock be like
oh i like the rock why do i feel so
conflicted about this monster doing
these horrible things because he's the
rock so the murder the darkness all
those things and then you juxtapose that
with basically having a team ensemble in
dr fate in having hawkman in these
introductions in cyclone and therefore
you feel the heroes are more heroic
juxtaposed to the rock and i think what
they're gonna do is make the rock more
like the current run of justice league
which is bendis marquez uh this really
i don't trust him he's doing good things
but i don't inherently believe he's on
our side and i think it's gonna be
opening act don't trust him second act
he's a good guy third act betrays us ah
so you're gonna think it's gonna
it's gonna move it's gonna loop back
into him being a villain that's right
they're not gonna do the venom round no
i think they're gonna go
they're going this way yeah
heroes think they've got an ally and
they need the trait right especially
when dwayne johnson is saying like i was
born to play black adam i'm going all
right were you born to play the the
comic accurate version or were you born
to play this version that you're playing
you know what i mean i mean the tagline
about the hierarchy the power structure
i think that is the ending i think he
shows his powerful hand and i think that
is why shazam two black adam anything is
going to shift dc into a more mystical
mythical powerful magical realm and then
you've got the underdog characters like
you're splitting the universe right
right well you got a brutal death in
here that was some cool stuff the
effects look great he's worked with this
guy before right i think yeah on jungle
cruise oh god the best edited movie i've
seen all year if you work with that
editor to get this clip assistant
clip was great was better than all the
jungle girls
the shots in this clip lasted more than
two seconds a piece actually
actually if we're gonna talk
cinematography i love that first
sweeping shot because if you think about
how shazam looked it was a lot of really
long frames right that kind of pulled
out and this doing that like push and
pivot up for whatever reason gives you a
more like you lean in instead of like
leaning back yeah i know it's a
fascinating thing to look at especially
because we everyone's familiar now with
the aesthetic that dc has established
with the shazam world with the wizard
and then here it's like oh but on the
the opposite end of this here's like the
darker reflection of that so the cave
felt spooky this feels haunting yeah the
cave felt like i don't want to go this
is like i got to get out of here yeah
yeah this is
gonna be fun regardless all right guys
what'd you think about our black adam
first look are you excited for it leave
your thoughts down below more
importantly follow koi when you got the
time hey let's do a
michael linden it might be dc fandom
going on right now but man you you
struck our hearts recently here's a
little backstory for everyone he
has been waiting for
no time to die to come out forever the
biggest bond fan i've ever known almost
every message we ever talked about was
about james bond over the years yes and
then he comes out and then he messes
with me saying one of the worst bond
movies ever
and i was like oh man we were just so
flabbergasted we could not believe this
is before we watched it if we could not
like comprehend like wow knowing that
you disliked it to that degree really
tempered my expectations we were just
like why
you
disliked it that much it was a real
moment that john and i had when we both
read your message together at the same
time when it just popped up at our feet
and i was like damn i don't believe it
no
so mikhail i'm hoping that the next bond
movie um played by robert pattinson
bill
26 times the charity not disappoint you
man
robert pattinson dresses up as blackface
as a transgender woman
you're gonna love it
[Music]
you